on the political impact of all this is
bringing in our chief election and
campaign correspondent Robert Costa Bob
you're on the road in New Hampshire
where Donald Trump is expected to appear
at a town hall tonight what is your
thought right now about how this
decision from a jury will affect the
2024 campaign
Good morning Tony Good To Be With You
from here in Manchester New Hampshire
checking in with our top Republican
sources for a candid assessment of all
of this it's clear they do not see this
moment as the beginning of the political
collapse of former president Donald
Trump but it is the possibility of a
slow erosion of support they expect some
candidates to start questioning Trump's
electability saying can he really win
over those Suburban voters should he be
the nominee in a general election next
year
have other 2024 candidates Bob already
begun to weigh in on on this decision
this is a real political Crossroads for
Trump's Rivals here in New Hampshire
people like former Arkansas governor Aza
Hutchison former New Jersey Governor
Chris Christie are holding Town Halls
we're speaking to Hutchinson in just a
few hours here in Manchester they're
trying to say to Republican voters look
you may have voted for Trump twice
before but it's time to move in a New
Direction the real looming question
though Beyond some some of those other
candidates and contenders is what's this
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis do he has
not yet entered the race his allies tell
CBS news they expect his Super PAC to
take sharper attacks on Trump in the
coming weeks but it's to be determined
about how exactly DeSantis will see this
political opening and Bob what are you
expecting from the town hall tonight
Trump is likely going to be asked not
only about what happened with the
verdict in the E Gene Carroll case but
he's going to be asked about all of
these ongoing legal challenges he is
facing what happened yesterday might
just be the crack of thunder before
larger storms on the horizon a possible
grand jury indictment in Georgia over
his pressure of election officials and
you have two Federal ongoing grand
juries one on the classified records the
other on January 6 Trump has denied any
wrongdoing but we expect him to be
defiant tonight at that town hall
Fair expectation I think Bob thank you
very much